okay humpback whales may have the most
complex acoustics
in the ocean uh they certainly have
more signaling than human language
the average human language and they also
had what might be called a global
internet millions of years before humans
did
they basically the ones we studied are
in southeast alaska and that's where
they make social calls
and feeding calls when they go to hawaii
that's romantic
they're supposed to mate and they sing
songs
so there's definitely a difference
between
alaskan vocalizations and hawaiian
vocalizations as it would be between
an average conversation human and an
average human song
there's all sorts of indications about
how intelligent they are
and uh anyway here's what some of them
sound like again
[Applause]
now there was a piece of song in there
you did hear a like that and that was a
piece of song
but mostly it doesn't sound like the
songs usually think of humpback whales
as making
because these are these are chatting
these are social calls and discussions
of things like
bubble nets and how to fish so we know
humpback whales also
make nets of bubbles to catch herring in
and usually if they
want to not if they don't make bubble
nets they just shovel
like krill which are a kind of shrimp
into their mouths with their long
flippers
but they've developed a skill in
southeast alaska
and i'm not sure where else in the world
uh where they build
nets of bubbles and
they basically shovel the they chase
the uh the herring into these nets
and um then they come up with their
mouths open and eat them
i'll show you a net in a minute but i
want to show you
a uh i want you to listen to what might
be considered an argument in humpback
whale
sometimes the bubble nets fail and
there's this kind of chatter argument
which if i wanted to anthropocentas at
anthropocentric
eyes uh this observation it would be
that they're arguing i was there where
were you see what you think
[Applause]
[Music]
so it doesn't sound very romantic does
it
so here's an example of bubble nets on
the right is an illustration
and from the air the diameter of those
spiraling bubble nets are about a
hundred feet
and they catch herring in them and we've
tried reproducing a bubble net in
miniature
and it's very difficult the idea we just
don't
have the technological intuition that
they have
whether it's boyle's law which has to do
with gas bubbles
and expanding or bernelli principle
buoyancy and you just have to have a lot
of technical knowledge
to catch fish in a net of bubbles
listen to this
[Applause]
so we heard that one day and it was the
tempo
and frequency range of human and i
thought of
trying to make uh talk to each other
underwater
when we were kids and that's what it
sounded like
it was a basically an attempt
by the humpback whales i think to
communicate inhuman
that's of course an over-interpretation
maybe but it sure sounded like they were
attempting to make human-like sounds
what you just heard was a humpback sound
so what we want is their language not
ours
so the first thing was to say everybody
quit talking so much in the boat
but um i think that was an attempt
of a non-human to communicate inhuman
to us not that far from seti when you
think about it
okay and here is an example of
a bubble net coming up with us nearby
taking pictures
and this is a feeding call again
by a humpback that we nicknamed miles
after miles davis the trumpeter see what
you think
if i were herring i would run from that
but it turns out that the humpbacks make
this sound that
is in resonance with the body of the
herring so they don't have much choice
at all
they're going to be scared into the net
by by the humpbacks
and they've been doing this for millions
of years we think
here's an example of a bubble net movie
[Applause]
killer
then we have to take pictures of their
tail flutes because that's how you
identify individual humpback whales
[Applause]
that's the id middle
so just looking at them from there you
go well they're pretty alien aren't they
they grow up on the same planet are on
the same star
and they have a global communication
system and there socially
network their social network is complex
and they use tools and in every other
way they're very intelligent we can't
put it down to their non-intelligence
that we haven't communicated with them
i would put it down to our kind of
anthropocentric viewpoint
of our own communication system but
we're working on it
so here's an example of an intelligence
filter the outline
russian letters english letters arabic
letters
russian phonemes dolphin whistles
humpback whale social and feeding calls
all
land within what we call the
intelligence filter if we got an
extraterrestrial signal
and it landed in this box that would be
news that would be really interesting
uh unfortunately squirrel monkey calls
ground squirrel calls and so on
as well as uh humpback whale and bird
song fall outside the intelligence
filter but elephant rumbles
fall in it so we're working with
different
increasing species to see who lands in
the intelligence filter
so the results are we can distinguish
astrophysics from an
intelligent extraterrestrial signal
we we know that other socially complex
species obey
the rules of information theory even an
extraterrestrial system would have to
obey the rules of information theory
in order for knowledge transfer to take
place that's an important point
you they cannot get around what
information theory measures they would
have to
their communication system would have to
obey information theory
so we're beginning to apply this to
any kind of message signaling
that is obtained from the allen
telescope array
eventually the terrestrial application
would be to be able to quantify
a different species ability to make
syntax out of their communication system
and we think they'd maximize this
because of the air recovery benefits
if we get an extra terrestrial signal
some anthropologists have said that
uh human complexity human cultural
complexity
led to human vocal complexity
so that if we measure the
communication complexity of an
extraterrestrial
signal we might also be able to obtain
at the same time be obtaining their
social complexity so
it's kind of a neat idea to measure the
social complexity mathematically
of an extraterrestrial civilization
so should we look up at the sky and say
are we alone
no i think we should well that's all
very romantic and stuff but we should be
paying attention to the non-human
communication systems on
earth we have millions to
to learn from